last week I couldn't get out of bed
actually for the last few weeks it's
been more than a little difficult I've
been getting up later than usual missing
buses and all-in-all feeling not so
awesome about a month ago I had a bad
incident and suffice it to say since
then leaving the house has gotten a
little difficult if you've ever been
down in the dumps or had a crappy
experience then I'm sure you want to
stat then along came a mobile game and I
can't believe this is a story I'm
telling either but this is what happened
Pokemon girl helped me get up in the
morning Pokemon girl was released early
last week in Australia before anywhere
else in the world and since then it's
been complete madness for my little full
person games SWAT team to see net across
the office and random people on the
streets everyone is catching pokémon all
the time I am catching pokémon all the
time at one point I had missed my bus
for three days running I'm supposed to
get up at 4:50 a.m. so I can be up in
time for a 5:30 a.m. bus so I can be in
the office place 6 a.m. to get game spot
news out by 9 a.m. Australian time zones
what had been happening is that my 450
alarm would go off I would wake up from
a series of nightmares completely
exhausted and lying until fixed the last
possible minute before I absolutely had
to be in an uber on my way to work when
afternoon I realized there was a Pokemon
Jim up at the shops where I normally
catch my 5:30 a.m. bus and the next
morning I got up on time for work I went
up to the shops in the dark and cold
with my app out so I could activate
poker stops as I went with the hope of
taking this Jim from what was probably a
school kid since the gym was right next
to my childhood school but hey this is
Pokemon not a picnic this story doesn't
really have a happy ending because as it
happens the servers were down so I
wasn't able to do anything anyway but it
did still get me up in the morning so I
guess you could say it was super
effective it got me to leave my house in
the afternoon to walk out to the park in
the cold and cats zubats
this is before I found out sooo bad
other Starbucks stores of Pokemon there
everywhere whether you want them there
it had me taking the long way home and
wandering through the rainy golf course
near my house to pick up pencils and
venusaur it had me socializing more with
coworkers and friends so we could talk
about what we caught which team we were
on and how high our levels were if the
reason my work friends gather in the
square near our office where people
throw down pokemon laws and the reason
why you'll hear someone gasp at their
desk having stumbled upon a really high
level creature
despite its issues / klungo is a game
that forms a strangely strong bond
between players particularly given it's
not even multiplayer it's a game that's
so popular right now that one of our
friends who decided to organize a small
Pokemon go excursion in Sydney ended up
with thousands of attendees many of whom
were wearing their team colors my
personal experience also isn't all that
unique a lot of you guys have been
saying that the game has helped you
improve your mental health and deal with
depression anxiety and agoraphobia this
isn't an isolated case for the developer
Niantic labs either who had similar
stories from players who picked up their
previous game ingress which had many of
the same location-based mechanics the
developers didn't intend this game to
have this sort of impact but it's now
something they've had in their
consciousness throughout the development
of pokemon card Pokemon go is just a
mobile game it's just an app and it's
often a really buggy and broken one at
that but it's an app that encourages
people both young and old to get outside
to walk new routes to talk to new people
and to get up in the morning and maybe
you don't need that and that's totally
fine but I did and I just think that's
really [ __ ] cool
you